اذا ينفذ طلاب جامعه سربون الفرنسيه
اعتصاما ضد قانون رفع سن التقاعد للمزيد
من التفاصيل حول هذا التطور ينضم الينا
فادي دهوك مراسل العربيه من العاصمه
الفرنسيه فادي الجديد فيما يتعلق من
السربون انت الان موجود في السربون
الزملاء يخبرونه الجديد في هذا الموضوع
وهذا الاعتصار
اهلا ابراهيم
في جامعه السربون كما ترون هناك حشد كبير
جدا من الطلاب هم ينفذون عصيا داخل
الجامعه والجامعه الان مطوقه من قبل عناصر
الشرطه بالكامل يمنع الدخول او الخروج من
الجامعه طبعا كان هناك محاولات من قبل
الطلاب للقفز عبر السور للانضمام الى
الطلاب الذين ينفذون هذا العصيان لكن قامت
الشرطه باعتقال على الاقل هناك طالبه تم
اعتقالها وتم اخذها من هذه المنطقه هذا
الامر ياتي فيما يستمر مجلس النواب في
جلسته المخصصه للتصويت على مذكرتي لحجب
الثقه عن الحكومه الفرنسيه التصويت لم يتم
بعد الجلسه ما تزال سريعه وهناك الان
كلمات للنواب لكن المشهد على الارض يزداد
توترا وهناك عدد من التظاهرات بدات تخرج
بالاضافه الى هذا العصيان الذي ينفذ هنا
في جامعه السربونان عندما نتحدث عن اسيان
على مستوى الطلاب ماذا يعني ذلك عدم حضور
المحاضرات اما ربما البقاء والاعتصام ايضا
داخل الجامعه مزيد من التفاصيل حول هذا
الموضوع
هم يقومون الان باضراب داخل الجامعه لا
يوجد محاضرات لن يحضروا هذه المحاضرات
والدروس لذلكم سموا هذه
المساله التي يقومون بها بالعصيان حتى
انهم كتبوا على جدران كثيره هنا كما ترون
هذه اللافته كتب عليها انهم يحتلون
الجامعه اي لا يريدون ان يكون هناك دروس
ومحاضرات كما ان هنا عدد كبير من الطلاب
الذين ينتظرون زملائهم لكي في او في لحظه
خروج هذه التظاهرات المتوقعه الان ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لك قبل ان نختم هل هناك اي
بوادر على حدوث ربما عصيان اخر او ربما
تصعيد على مستوى اضطرابات خلال الساعات
القادمه خصوصا اذا ما تم عدم حجب الثقه
الحكومه في البرلمان الفرنسي
نعم التصعيد هو سيد الموقف الساعات
المقبله لان حجب الثقه لا يحظى بفرص كثيره
ليتم لذلك هناك قطاعات كثيره تعلن انها
ستنضم لهذه الاعتصامات والاضرابات وايضا
التظاهرات حتى يضغطوا اكثر على الحكومه
لاجبار الرئيس منو المايكرو بسحب هذا
القانون شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه المعلومات
هذه الدهوك مراسل العربيه كنت معنا من
جامعه العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس